okay we're here back on YouTube what
does the red square on your outfit
signify Alexis so this means we're all
in the red in other words we're all in
debt it's a symbol that came out of
Montreal when they may have this student
a protest against tuition hikes but the
debt collective which is a group that I
work with has sort of taken it on
because it's a tie that binds the 99% is
that we're all in debt but that's
usually a conservative talking well
we're taking it over we're really
appropriating it so we can work in
something I mean you do I'm sure you do
understand you realize of course someone
has steeped in the politics is you that
that's the reason the Conservatives give
for why we can't do any social spending
we're too in debt already how can we how
can we give unemployment insurance to
people we're in debt everything is we're
in debt we can't do anything but they
conflate this idea that government is
the same in an individual right and the
government has to balance its budget and
tighten its belt but I also think that
the reason that we as individuals are in
so much debt is because the government
has been shrinking and turning itself
over to the private sector and you know
we don't have basic services we don't
have free education like other parts of
the country and so we're trying to push
back on that and say look debt is the
way that Wall Street occupies our lives
so what would happen if instead of
unions for workers we had unions for
debtors and we're trying to build unions
for debtors you know do you know there
was a time when the United States wasn't
in debt do you know there was a time it
was during about a month of the Andrew
Jackson administration and that was
literally the only time you know I'm not
making it as recently as the 70s the
debt was like the national debt not the
deficit was like 75 million million not
billion million that's how we used to
live well but the analogy of a family I
think drive us on the wrong course when
there's I mean there when we say you
know we have to balance our budget like
my family does well does your family
mint money I mean come on yes
what happens to my smile where the
Knox's yeah we also families also don't
borrow from China yes that's right ed
begley what can the average American do
consistently that will have the most
positive effect on the environment
that's a great question because you know
we do so many things like recycle I mean
most responsible certainly people out
here in Liberal California we recycle
and we do we do things we bring our own
bag to the grocery store is it doing
anything or it is the air in LA from
1970 when I started to date even though
there's four times the cars millions
more people there's a fraction of the
smog it's much cleaner so we did a lot
that's a big secure that's big as the
laws exactly catalytic converters on
cars right power plants all that the EPA
they started to enforce the EPA signed
the Clean Air Act signed by Richard
Nixon by the way and as far as
California goes people should know you
have a lot of power because this state
is so big when we do something yes very
often the rest of the country has to
like Detroit cannot make a car that they
cannot sell to 40 million people which
is California right so when we raise our
mileage standards they had to go up for
the whole country so no you have that
power per capita three per capita energy
use throughout the country has been like
this since the late seventies been like
that in California because we we
promoted efficiency so people pick the
low-hanging fruit first energy-efficient
thermostat energy-saving light bulbs you
know right a bike of weather and fitness
permit take public transportation if
it's available near you all that stuff
is very cheap home gardening home
composting do that cheap and easy stuff
first you will save money then maybe one
day could buy some solar panels yeah
guys you a question what is something
that environmentalists do that may be a
fad that's an empty gesture really
doesn't do much is there anything like
that that you can think of you know I
think it's important to recycle but some
people look at recycling and they go
well I've done my part I put some
bottles in the thing but we have such a
problem with single-use plastic even
though people put it in that bin
those plastic bottles it's best not to
use that stuff at all to get away from
ginger you class
you know what week hundreds Michael
though Israel does it water Imogen
yeah it is rayul is leads the world in
recycling water all the water the sewage
water no no one wants to drink although
people that happens you know they've
treat sewage water and then it winds up
that's drinking water wenches like when
you're at a camel urine you got it when
you're at breakdown you could totally
use it for agriculture your options of
course was probably better it's full of
[ __ ] and all water is recycled water
water has been recited since the
dinosaurs roamed the earth you know at
nature have a wonderful job of that we
need to do what's known as biomimicry
and allow it to percolate down through
the into the aquifer and use that water
again and rainwater we need to collect
not just in the aquifers but in rain
barrels you know cheap rain barrels then
underground as I'm doing in a more
expensive system editor bill just to go
back to the original question isn't the
idea that individuals can have an impact
on climate change sort of faulty don't
we actually need real public policy
absent that's such a great point to make
it's like saying we could have defeated
Hitler by just saving 10 as they did
know it this is a giant giant problem
that can only be solved with public
policy like a carbon tax the oceans
we're going to lose the oceans you can't
survive on earth without the oceans I
don't know what people think they're
doing oh so I won't eat fish that this
this idea this business it blows my mind
the human propensity to just adapt
I see people wearing the masks in
Beijing and New Delhi
really you wouldn't want to take more
fundamental steps to cure the problem oh
well I guess I can't breathe without a
mask unless I go outside I guess there
are no fish or foot you know a jellyfish
and cockroaches for the rest of my life
yeah in a little salt will be great but
Gandhi said if people lead in
governments follow and you can't do it
alone I'm not suggesting recycling or
light bulbs is going to solve climate
change but we need to do that and then
get governments to really move and
through legislation the Clean Air Act
helped us get the air cleaner in LA it
wasn't just people driving electric cars
like maybe there's a Clean Air Act the
enforce I'm sorry and we need to have
more of that
and we need to push the countries around
the world that are emitting so much co2
what about the Chinese what about the
Indians what about Mexico well Obama
finally made a deal with the Chinese now
it's not a perfect one but it's better
than anyone that came before oh look I
don't agree with you at all but we need
to continue to keep the throttle on the
metal here to make sure that these guys
don't keep bending the rules in violet
okay is there a law you can recommend
I'm looking for a car seriously a very
good car I Drive a Nissan Leaf which is
a great car pure electric but a one size
fits all terrific car american-made is
the Chevy Volt because you can drive in
drive it on electric up to 40 miles and
if you want to drive to New York or San
Francisco you can drive I have it I have
a Tesla those ashlyn is a great car I
love it yeah yeah I mean I have the
original it's a little small you can't
fit into it if you have an erection
right if you can get an erection you
don't need a ribbon imagine saying
you're never actually driven at that
know I've tried drugs
but yeah I know but why I'm a perpetual
erection hey I'm not going there there
sits the doctor more than four hours
there's a word for that you know
priapism
you really erection that won't go away
cars and dicks with Bill Maher yeah
maybe I should be wearing this yeah
we're gonna go from there yeah that
could be that could be the erection that
won't go away cause yeah my red patch
all right Ellen would that be I didn't
mind
a blow oh yeah yeah and it wouldn't
throw below it'd be a lot bigger than
that little [ __ ] red square over
there nice right
yes I see we'll think that's that's a
communist thing because Red Square just
said it you know red is the color of
communism I'm not scared of that all
right
not that I'm a communist - in a failed
system Jeff would would ending the drug
war have an effect on our policy of mass
incarceration well there's a softball
right down the middle you know I was in
this jail and a lot my opening joke was
some of you have been in here or locked
up for possession of less marijuana than
I have in my lungs right now so many
people I spoke to in jail are there for
reg yeah minimum
for drug offenses first timers and he
takes somebody who sold wheat I sold
weed in high school I sold it in college
well when I started comedy attention if
anyone absolutely it was a comics or
finagler we don't we we're not like
actors who have to like wait tables we
always figure out a way that we don't
have to work right telling me yeah yeah
I sold joints of my prom it was very
profitable actually very profit but if I
had gotten in trouble luckily I did and
I don't know if I would have survived in
what a modern day jail looks like you
take basically a guy selling weed and
you throw him into jail he started
doesn't start to play down his crime he
starts to build it up and become tougher
yes and he gets criminalized inside jail
and now it was so frightening about what
I saw what what quantity did you buy
when you were a dealer I used to go to
Washington Square Park and pretend to
play chess at midnight and if I like you
know a quarter an ounce of weed and then
roll it into marijuana so loose joints
from Washington Square Park you bought a
vet you know dude you put a ring on it
when I
I was in the catering business aw yeah
that's that's not a dealer that's not a
dealer I was a deal I mean I were not a
big dealer but I would buy a pound right
and then divide it because I found out
16 ounces so I divided into 17 parts
nice the one nice that was what we
called the head tax it could be that
listen Medical Marijuana saved my life I
was dying of anorexia very hard okay all
right thank you everybody thank you
panel we'll see you